welcome back to segment 3 with kevin
o'leary all right
two words Steve Jobs the toughest
bastard you've ever met he is tough he
was you know I went to his his so I
called him up
I said listen Steve you're
two-and-a-half percent of the market and
we are your nose right what year is this
this is 1998 before Aplin ruled the
universe
they were wobbly situation turn a half
percent share my development cost for 54
million your first titles you know I was
the number one title on the Mac platform
reading and math and I called him up and
I said let's leave I need to meet with
unique anomic start working for me
and so Charles I can meeting with you so
we go out to Cupertino and job shows up
with probably seven other executives in
the room I'm where with my head sales
guys I said Steve thanks for coming out
and you have a very simple request we
didn't have to give me fifty four
million dollars if you want me to
develop the next cycle of titles for the
Mac because it's a there's no economics
that makes sense for me he looked at me
and he just started to boom rate me ver
rollick every swear word in the world
just he said I'm you out of your feet
and they got up and out of his charity
circled around and said you be some
beefy P and looking at him I'm stunned
like the guy is just beating me up
verbally I'm used to hard time so you
know whatever I said hey listen this is
all great but are you going to give me
the 54 minutes and he said get outta
here get in the parking is just abusive
like crazy I said okay this is over I
walk out to the parking lot and this is
one of these windows you have to roll up
to the bottom and he rolls up he's
yelling at me from definitely parking
lot hey I looked up and said so do we
have a deal or not call me tomorrow
like if the guy just wanted to beat me
up he was I guess frustrated that he's
had a lot of pressure all that good so
anyways at the end of the day we
remained in
one player on the Mac platform we built
a business offic years later I met
Wozniak and who is a completely
different kind of guy but I understand
how jobs work there's a certain amount
of fear in that organization for him I
mean he chairs into people after he
looks at the AI air or anything of a
product and he'll rip their heads yeah
like people don't get in an elevator
with it okay so you have this line about
if you don't come to work on Saturday
don't bother coming to work on Sunday or
Monday are you serious or do you value
some balance for your employee no no
there's no balancing work for me and
here's the whole point
see I've discovered that this is the way
it works if you want balance go work for
a company that's nine-to-five buy a dog
go see your kid play baseball but you're
never going to get rich we work for me
generally speaking you get options in
the company I expect you to work 24/7
like an animal until we're successful so
that you can cash out you're trying to
put this important freedom when you work
for me so my employees only when I need
them say look here's how we work this is
going to work for you give it a shot
maybe you work for three years long
years you cash out that's great don't
come here to make friends
I'm not going to be your friend come
here to make money it's that simple
not everybody can take that but the ones
that do come in we form powerful teams
we're vicious competitors that's the
kind of guy I want work for long-dormant
okay so one thing is you can call the
lot of bad words you're right I will say
this everyone has an ego it's how you
manage it but I did not detect a single
hint of arrogance in this book which is
I think surprising people would have
expected you to be somewhat arrogant but
my question is you did one thing with
Michael Carrick which I think even I'm
not mad enough to do which is when we
brought along to be your partner you
made him see her in an equal partner now
imagine imagine you had vested I guess
to some extent so it was easier to do
that but that's a big thing to do I mean
because the company had been around so
what is your view on partnerships and
why are they so important so here's the
way I look at it you know the key to
success as an entrepreneur is not to
understand your strengths it's to
understand your weaknesses now here's
what I do I was weak at logistics man
and shipping logistics bores the crap
outta me I just not interested in it
when Walmart came on board and said look
we're going to change this whole
industry we're going to make you our
guys in education software we had the
challenge of moving 80 million units I
can't do that that's not my skillset
micro Pyrrhic on the other hand is
myopically focused at that kind of thing
and i knew that he's one of our
shareholders I went to Parsons and
listen why don't you leave your PE firm
okay I'll give up the title of CEO
you're going to be a CEO you're number
one role is going to be logistics
because if we are not successful at this
we're going to fail this is the only
thing that matters is shipping these
units all around the world who looked at
me and said what's in it for me I said
you know what I own a ton of stock lots
and lots of it I'll make a deal with you
I'll make us equal partners and this is
how I'll talk in the broken writing it I
looked at every transit transaction
where I've made money not just learning
company storage now you're Larry funds
deals before that all the deals where I
made money were partnerships all the
ones why had catastrophic failures are
the things I'm trying to do myself so
I've learned now that it's much better
to partner with somebody who actually
throws in the hole so many people yeah
really people of course but in the case
of Perak it was it was actually three
people myself Eric and Scott Murray
so purpose logistics I'm sales and
marketing and Marie's the CFO we were
the most feared management team in the
consumer software business and we got if
we called you
you know bad times are coming your way
because either we're buying your company
ready to compete with you you mentioned
word here better to be respected or
you're both respected for the normal
colors your relational respire roles the
reason people respect you is they fear
you that's what happens if they actually
have the same thing okay but again only
one can be both it what's more important
who you know or what you know and that's
a good one
No okay you've eaten I say it's very
respectfully but you talked about them
in the book you've eaten cat food
amazing stories of former selves by
myself and who scraped gum off the floor
which one changed your life more when
you look back you're like scraping gum
off the floor because I got fired in to
change the direction for me forever fair
enough fair enough you say money goes to
bad people they're not to bad ideas
which i think is a very true and genius
thing to say expand on that idea so the
concept is that you know people say well
you have to be really nice guy to make
money that's not true many [ __ ] make
lots of money money goes to the path of
least resistance it doesn't care about
your personality it's looking for an
opportunity to grow and expand with the
least risk with the least you know
resistance to success so I've learned
that I work with many people that I
would never be friends with but I make
money with them and I respect them for
that many many many people I can
certainly keep the emotion of that
decision you mentioned that altruism and
capitalism have to coexist my question
is I see that some extent but in your
mind does everything have to make money
yes everything everything has to make
money or have performance metrics they
forgot even a charity see I talked about
the five proof I'm sure my strategy is
very simple because I get bombarded with
the press to give away money and happy
to do so I took the same percentage
every year of my income after tax and I
pick five charities for five years and
they get the same amount every year for
five years that five years is over I get
five new charities and that way I could
stay focused make a difference they know
that they're gonna have some kind of a
turn for me and so in that way I can I
can do this in a way that I've got that
deal done and I know it's gonna work
agree or disagree greed is good which is
a quote from the fictional character
Gordon Gekko you talk about greed is
good but do you agree with disagree
I do I agree and I think weight is not
only good it's wonderful it's wonderful
to expect next question that's my next
question is a few more things there's a
quote from Douglas Ivysaur former CFO
and REE CEO of coca-cola he basically
says quote when your competitor is
drowning stick a hose in his mouth end
quote do you agree or disagree with that
I agree but I would pour boiling or
into that post out alright next quote
dick Parsons former chairman of Time
Warner current current chairman of
Citigroup quote when you negotiate leave
a little something on the table end
quote in other words don't get so much
like every penny you could because it's
a short life you're going to run into
the same business people and if they
feel you had the massive upper hand and
it wasn't a fair transaction they're not
really going to want to deal with you
again is dick is mr. Parsons right or
wrong well it's right in some ways but I
look at a different way the best deals
are ones where both sides are unhappy or
interesting okay not happy I'd have both
are happy they suspend why because if
you're both unhappy you've both left
both sides lots on the table in other
words you never got what you want to be
of the other side that's a good deal and
generally if you didn't have a great
partnership what is stronger and this I
think is more investing question that it
really would apply to management on
spyro's well what is a stronger feeling
greed or fear fear I think there is a
better motivator than greed is the stock
market efficient in terms of information
do you have massively more access to
information than regular drove he's
looking at investing in IBM or Apple no
the market is I'm not accusing Reubens
oh no no no I don't I don't do insider
trading anyways I mean I don't actually
train at all because I'm a finisher I'm
a very fun saw I prepare you know
prohibited from trading so I look at it
this way the market has become extremely
volatile because there's lots of
transparency and loss of information and
we now have high-speed trading programs
to do this so I anticipate that we're
gonna have two or three percent means
every day for the rest of my life in the
market okay you talk about business
being in your DNA you've also heard
about the line about you know Warren
Bennis
professor at USC says leaders are they
born or are they made so my first
question is you are held a sales person
are sales people born or are they made
well everybody's born it's the way I
look at it is great sales people are
able
to live with very strict metrics so I
hire all my salespeople
and I probably I look for in them is can
they get up in the morning and say I
want to go to bed at night richer than I
woke up that's the hallmark of a great
salesman because they put on conditions
that's how it burst you know sales is
tough and only two thirds of your sales
force are gonna work out long-term most
of my firings occur in the sales area
because it's clear to me it's not
working it it's a combination of
relationships a little art a little
science and in an organization the
people I respect the most but not the
CFL's the CFO's it's the salespeople
that's where I have a kidney speak
couple more questions uh don't you say
go let others determine your worth I
totally get that now let me ask you
something your best sales guy walks into
your office he says boss it's time for
me to go start my own company
do you a side up and so much to stay he
change his mind or see say I want less
to me would be nicer in here boy look at
me
no no I'm gonna pour hot oil on no no
people don't want to stay I never try
and keep him that doesn't make sense I
mean if he's found a better opportunity
but I would never invest in a Salesman
because they're not generally the best
managers but are the best salesmen never
promote the best salesmen to run stairs
yeah so there is a different little
great okay final questions are sort of
sub questions regarding your investing
that track record of on dragons then in
Shark Tank so how many companies have
you invested all the two trucks oh
that's plenty pioneer perfect 20 how
much money of universal album oh I have
to add it up the deals are in size the
height biggest one was three million and
the smallest one was five thousand bucks
what did you get what percentage for
that room um that deals were royalty
deals was 51% but there's something
about reading the statistics belieber
estimate this is an interesting line let
me tell you the stats page for
investment is gonna be shocking to you
since for me from 1992 to 2001 in ten
deals got liquid and they
the shareholders money in grooming on
this since 2002 today is one in 25
returns on venture investing actually
negative on drag is that in Shark Tank
every time as a handshake
you see if they're like that only one in
three of those close the two other three
village survival villages of the
investment portfolio including the
British the American and the Canadian
where there are hundreds of deals done
117 has made money I don't help a
dispensary capital investing but I got a
sense from the little icing on what I've
read and what I've heard it's more
almost like a bank loan or like a
certain level is changing now because
banks aren't lending so real copies are
coming on people practicin is this is
the venture capital is the American Idol
of intricate yeah if you put your
product on there
truly and people see it four times a we
a second miss sales are going up forty
five percent so I argue that I'd rather
invest in a company listen consumer go
to service I'd have an ungracious ticket
for free advertising but making money
with it now mr. Dees would be telling
with royalties for some percentage of
capital T batch the investor form factor
yeah so I wanted to work sub questions
on this any I sensor from your
investment on shows yes there was one
called
IQ zone in season two which was an app
with the early apps for Nokia cell
phones that was the next step it was a
good outcome because another one that's
coming on very very well for ticket
gloss which is from two seasons ago with
zero to four hundred thousand sales this
thing is taking office building a brand
the rest are living dead basically you
know I'm writing checks and that frankly
that's gonna be the ratio it's gonna be
two in eighteen all right we could shop
for hours fascinating you do a great job
of telling the right story is only from
a pilot biography perspective this book
was probably more entertaining than most
buyers and from good money and business
lessons goes great person it's available
in bookstores online many great places
$10 you can finish thank you very much